[Musique]
ah qu est ce que vous pensez si je vous
parle de sujets tabous de sujets qui
fâchent de sujets qui quand on les
aborde provoque systématiquement la
polémique au rock systématiquement de
longs débats
ce sont des sujets qu'on évite d'aborder
en famille ou avec des collègues
moi j'ai quatre sujets qui me viennent
naturellement en tête les religions la
politique
le football et l'écologie alors pour
certains de ces sujets je peux tout à
fait comprendre qu'ils aient une
polémique clinique qui naissent prenez
la religion par exemple avec des des
questions comme est ce que dieu existe
il y at il une vie après l'amour votre
on croire en mon petit bouquin qui a été
écrit que ton croire en quelqu'un qui a
vécu il ya deux mille ans je peux tout à
fait comprendre qu'on puisse se prendre
la tête et je pense que d'ailleurs le
débat risque de déplaire au ghana
en ce qui concerne la politique là c'est
un c'est un grand classique qui par
minute a déjà eu une discussion sur la
politique qui a bien terminé
franchement moi je n'en vois pas si vous
hésitez mais si tu hésites tu peux
encore faire un test si tempête
quant à prochaine réunion de famille à
bord de la politique et du merapi
c'est ça finit bien ensuite le football
là je vous avoue c'est très personnel
mes grands parents sont originaires de
liège sont des grand supporter du
standard de liège et je vous avoue que
certains petits enfants n'ont pas suivi
les lignes de conduite familiale et
certains héritages sont en péril moi y
compris
et donc c'est un peu l'occasion pour moi
aujourd'hui devenir un peu redoré son
blason mettre ici à liège ce soit et
puis enfin l'écologie l'écologie c'est
un peu le clou le dernier arrivé mais
qui est déjà très très bien intégré dans
le club sélect des sujets tabous
d'ailleurs la preuve dans un de mes
dîners de famille récemment il ya eu une
énorme prise de tête sur un gratin
bourjac alors les bourreaux let étaient
des bio et donc on a eu un débat sur
est-ce que le bio est une arnaque des
supermarchés pour que ça coûte plus cher
est-ce que les pesticides sont vraiment
mauvais pour la santé
est ce que ma petite cousine à des
problèmes d'allergie à cause des
percussions perturbateurs endocriniens
et ça a continué comme ça encore et
encore jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un
dernières années le dessert ou enfin
trop duré le débat alors moi mon travail
je suis conseiller en environnement
donc je sensibilise les gens aux enjeux
contemporains sur l'écologie est donc
dans ce genre de discussion belle j'ai
un avis j'ai vraiment envie de
participer et pourtant j'hésite à
rencontrer dans le débat je me sens
vraiment mal à l'aise en fait à
alimenter ce débat qui finalement mène
souvent à pas grand chose
et donc je fais peut-être allez-vous ce
soir je voudrais deux situations et vous
allez me dire la situation que vous
préférez situations différentes
vous êtes en train de vous balader en
forêt vous avez vos enfants qui jouent
autour de vous vous avez le soleil qui
réchauffe votre visage vous avez le
chant des oiseaux vous avez vous voyez
des papillons
vient se poser sur le bout de votre main
situation numéro deuxième situation vous
êtes ici à liège place saint lambert
il est huit heures du matin vous avez
une petite pluie fine qui vient vous
fouetter le visage
vous avez le doux son des klaxons qui
vous viennent vos oreilles donc respirer
cette bonne odeur d'essence et de
particules fines qui rentre dans votre
peau vous avez des gens stressés qui
viennent bousculer donc que vous marchez
qui parmi vous rendrez la solution
numéro à lever la main s'il vous plaît
merci
j'y prendrai la solution numéro deux
places à lembeye 8 heures du matin
un courageux l'écologie devrait être une
évidence
je ne comprends pas comment on peut se
prendre la tête
à propos de l'environnement la nature
devrait être logique devrait couler de
soi
et pourtant ce n'est pas le cas alors du
coup j'ai essayé de le comprendre
pourquoi je vous suis un peu sur un peu
intéressé à ce qu'il disait autour de
moi mes amis à ma famille et j'en suis
arrivé à une première notion qui me
paraît assez intéressante c'est la
notion de carte du monde on vit tous ici
dont le moins de monde mais on a tous
une carte différente pour le lire je
vous donner un exemple la transition
écologique par ici peut-être que
monsieur quand je lui parle de
transition écologique avec sa casquette
du monde
eh ben il va voir une éolienne ils
veulent voir un panneau photovoltaïque
il va vouloir une voiture électrique
verra l'innovation c'est la technique il
va se dire là c'est ça qui va nous
permettre de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
madani sy va peut-être avoir une vision
un peu plus cro magnon vide et que ben
voila si la transition écologique c'est
une perte de confort
c'est un retour à l'âge de pierre je
n'aurais plus ma voiture je n'aurais pu
mon frigo c'est vraiment un retour en
arrière
monsieur la balle au fond on va
peut-être avoir un scénario beaucoup
plus catastrophistes
un scénario plus à la mad max l'idée que
nous ne le monde va s'effondrer
il a tenu un bouquin sur la clope ce
logis dont qui est l'étude de
l'effondrement de notre société moderne
le genre de bouquin qui vous maintient
éveillé toute la nuit que je pensais
madame nadeau fond on va peut-être avoir
une image encore différente une image du
bisounours
l'idée que vers l'est si on fait tous
des petits défauts alors si on fait tous
pousser nos légumes
ici on fait tous des petits gestes
éco-responsables on va pouvoir
transitionner tous ensemble alors
fatalement quand je vois tous et toutes
ses cartes du monde différent je
commence à comprendre pourquoi il existe
une certaine polémique à cause sur le
sujet de l'écologie
pourquoi il ya certes un débat qui
naissent mais je ne suis pas encore
satisfait est-ce que vous avez remarqué
que ces cinq dernières années
on parle beaucoup beaucoup plus
d'écologie dans les médias sur les
réseaux sociaux et même maintenant
récemment en belgique
la politique est là il ya énormément de
messages qui circulent ou des messages
qui sont véhiculées par le gouvernement
par les médias intéresse pas par vos
amis par des institutions par des sd et
on retrouve très régulièrement dans ses
messages
la notion de nous devons faire des
efforts les citoyens doivent faire des
efforts et je me suis demandé est ce que
on a vraiment rester comprendre parce
qu'on s'est vraiment intéressé à
l'impact que ces messages couverts
doivent sûr nous citoyens je vous donne
un exemple la viande alors l'industrie
des viandes a un impact absolument
catastrophique sur internet
nous devrions manger beaucoup moins
viande mais qu'est ce que ça représente
moi pour moi la viande c'est un bon
steak frites j'adore maintenant je
trouve cela délicieux
voilà si je devais me passer l'avion je
devrais pas changer ma manière de manger
je devrais changer ma manière de faire
les courses doit vous changer mes
habitudes je devrais manger du tofu
vingt sept ça c'est vraiment pas évident
pour moi de me passer dix ans et en plus
de ça je ne sais pas ce que vous faites
ou auprès entendre quand le soleil
revient et moi j'invite tous mes potes
quelques bières un maximum de saucisses
et ont fait un mineur de bach du coup
voilà pour moi c'est quelque chose de
très important et donc se passe quand u2
nous a dit que dans le passé tout ça un
autre exemple la voiture alors un tiers
des émissions de co2 sur la planète sont
dues aux transports nous devrions
prendre beaucoup moins la voiture mais a
motivé c'est extrêmement pratique une
voiture on va travailler avec une
voiture d'un concurrent
après on va voir ses amis on va faire
ses loisirs il ya plus de ça la voiture
m'ont personnellement quand j'avais 19
ans et mon permis et une voiture à
disposition
j'ai pu faire ce que je voulais quand je
joue je me suis senti libre et
indépendant et donc voici je m'entraîne
la voiture j'ai aussi abandonner cette
liberté et cette indépendance
j'étais un exemple par rapport à ça on
peut continuer avec heures l'avion
l'avions dit ce que ça représente
l'avion mais c'est le rêve c'est le
voyage et le dépaysement l'énergie
qu'est-ce que ça
l'énergie c'est un ordinateur c'est une
des visions c'est le chauffage en fait
l'énergie c'est du confort et donc quand
on regarde en fait tous ces messages qui
nous parle de faire des efforts ont un
impact bien plus important que ce que
l'on peut imaginer sur nos citoyens on
ne demande pas que de faire des efforts
en fait on nous demande de faire des
sacrifices des sacrifices qui est
présent des choses super intendante
répondre
alors
ces sacrifices comment sortir du coût de
cette paix de cette notion de sacrifice
comment sortir de cette notion de
culpabilité de cette notion d'anxiété
j'aimerais du coup répondre essayer de
répondre à cette question une bonne
raison une
quel est selon vous le point commun
entre martin luther king le taux
suggestions positives et le film demain
alors peut-être que certains d'entre
vous j'imagine la plupart d'entre vous
connaissent martin luther king est un
pasteur moi qui dans les années 60 a
prononcé un célèbre le discours où il a
prononcé ses célèbres moai rennes depuis
et donc il dit lundi je fais un rêve que
dans lost dans notre société
un jour les gens puissent naître ego je
fais un rêve qu'un jour un blanc et un
noir puissent s'asseoir à la même table
je fais un rêve que les petits mes
petits enfants ne seront pas jugés à la
couleur de leur peau mais bien à la
valeur de leur caractère
l'autosuggestion positive est une
technique qu'on utilise notamment pour
arrêter de fumer
alors arrêtez de fumer de fumer est une
entraîne une dépendance physique mais
aussi les devants dans ce mental ça
devient une habitude de vinofed fumée et
donc la technique propose de se
concentrer sur le positif de se
concentrer sur ce qu'on va pouvoir
récupérer quand on aura arrêté de fumer
donc on va pouvoir récupérer par exemple
une bonne élève on va pouvoir récupérer
le goût des aliments
on va pouvoir récupérer le fait de faire
un exercice physique sans être fatigué
va pouvoir récupérer le joli dans et de
jolis sons et le film demain peut-être
que certains d'entre vous dans la seine
question de le voir c'est un
documentaire français qui est sorti en
2015 et qui fait le constat au début du
film de dire l'humanité
actuellement est en péril suite à
l'effondrement de nos écosystèmes dans
la suite du film
il propose en fait des alternatives
concrètes des alternatives qui existent
déjà et qui fonctionne dans le monde
actuel et qui parle de différentes
thématiques comme l'énergie la politique
l'éducation ou même l'agriculture
d'ailleurs le film a eu un impact assez
positif sur mon tueur en projet ici
liégeois je sais pas si vous connaissez
la ceinture alimentaire dans le deuxième
set
c'est un projet en fait il met en
relation des agriculteurs locaux avec
des magasins ici à liège
et finalement vous citoyen liégeois
c'est ça propose une production de
nourriture qui est vrai qu'à la fois
l'environnement et le travailleur alors
finalement mais quel est le point commun
entre un pasteur noir une technique pour
arrêter de fumer est un film français
il démarre tous d'un constat extrêmement
négatif la condition des noirs aux états
unis est absolument intolérable fumer
nuit gravement à la santé et des
écosystèmes de la planète sont en péril
l'un des messages qui sont véhiculés ici
ne sont pas des messages de haine
ce ne sont pas des messages qui
encouragent la violence
encouragea la division on n'essayait pas
ici de chercher un coupable
l'idée est de proposer une alternative
est de proposer un rêve une histoire
commune et le chemin pour y arriver
implique des changements et ces
changements seront bien plus facile à
mettre en place a passé si nous arrivons
à nous concentrer sur le positif qui en
découlent alors je ne suis pas naïf je
sais très bien que tout le monde
n'arrête pas de fumée du joueur en main
juste en pensant à
positif je sais que changer nos
habitudes reste un énorme défi mais si
nous voulons
si nous voulons arriver à changer d'un
mode de vie si nous voulons arriver à
entraîner d'autres gens avec nous nous
devons absolument éviter le piège de
l'anxiété le piège du sacrifice le piège
du sentiment de culpabilité au lieu de
juste dénoncer
n'hésitons pas aussi à proposer
envisageons aussi les bénéfices que l'on
pourra en retirer une meilleure santé
des retombées positives sur notre notre
quartier sur l'environnement sur nos
enfants et inspirons nous de ce qui se
fait déjà autour de nous mais solutions
qui fonctionnent des alternatives
concrètes et apportons aussi notre petit
gars en scène notre histoire et nos
rêves alors je sais que cela ne sauvera
peut-être pas la planète mais je pense
que nous pourrons enfin déguster
tranquillement un bon gratin de
courgettes en famille et se concentrer
sur le vrai débat qui est finalement qui
d'anderlecht du standard sera champion
cette année
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]